hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to SCP containment breach
the full version of this game version
1.0 has finally been released and they
added a whole bunch of new stuff I
couldn't even read you the entire
changelog but I think there are four new
scps which means four new monsters or
objects for me to interact with and
there are a few more improvements on the
game in general in terms of sound
ambience all that jazz it should prove
to be a terrifying experience and it has
been far too long since the last time
that I played it and I hope that you
guys who have not heard of this game
before get a real kick out of it's one
of the scariest games I've ever played
my playlists on it is like 40 episodes
deep there is a lot of content if you
want to find out more about this game
and you can go to the SCP containment
breach wiki or not the containment
breach wiki but the SCP wiki in general
and you can find out a lot more about
the monsters within this wonderful game
now they did change up a lot of what the
hell is that that's new okay
I was under the assumption that I'd seen
this all already whoa what is it
laughing about seriously ok I am in a
different place and I remember I was
usually the intro sequence
oh I pushed the button but nothing
happens
hmm is this okay
goddamn they added a lot of ambience not
the good kind
oh well well then oh my god
one of the biggest things about this
game has always been the sound and one
of the things that I always harp on in
terms of horror games is the sound in
man it was already good what huh
interesting we have two new doors that
have key cards I don't remember a
hallway like that I played this game so
much that I know the entire game front
and back but it looks like they've kind
of changed up the recipe quite a bit
because I don't recognize much of this
oh that's Billy if you guys don't know
about Billy but Billy's up ballerina
dancer here he goes dance along the
screen Oh Billy don't don't go now you
need to go get out of here Billy thank
you okay so that's Billy and we're gonna
see a lot of him later really up close
and in person now my objective here is
to try to find the new stuff as quickly
as possible but you guys know how that
usually goes and I haven't even saved
Simon there we go games saved I am NOT
good with this it has been quite a while
since last I played okay definitely
getting back into the mood of it I
wonder
nuki that is very red snob there hi
Billy
okay bye Billy I'm not going that way
just yet oh this is gonna be a new
experience all over again it seriously
has been far too long since I played
this game I don't even know why I took a
break but there are a lot of uh a lot of
gaps in between the release of this game
it is hardened okay let's jump it on the
roof we're on the ground and it got
quiet oh that ain't good
what is that an elevator there's not
supposed to be an elevator over here
should I walk into the elevator of blood
what Arden Oh spent so long I don't I
don't even remember oh come on no okay I
don't even remember what was there
before but oh god I know that I knew
about that forgot about that but I know
about that some of you guys may not have
known about that but I did oh poor fella
just a regular old scientist trying to
make ends meet in a world of demons
monsters everything trying to kill
otherworldly entities okay I recommend I
recognize this place
hello did they improve you I never even
really caught you out of the corner of
my eye before I don't know why we there
we go yay okay so all of the information
in here has pretty much been gone over
before and many times over so I don't
really need to repeat anything except
for those of you who are new to this I
highly recommend going to the wiki and
finding out more about this game I will
try to tell you as much as I can but I
may be screaming like a little girl and
running away like a baby so don't make
me a mum Pandy sometimes it flips my
camera around and it's not me the gamer
okay bye
you were there you were there why the
hell's going on no whoa I don't even
have a gas mask I don't even have a gas
mask I don't have a battery for that
either I'll get rid of it there we go
what the hell by going what's going on
it didn't dump me off at the beginning
play so I don't have anything that I
need ya ah damn and I don't have that
hell of a night just a loser
wandering around the world without
anything I believe in I pass on
I don't Billy hey good to see you again
the closed door thank you
oh you don't feel it you don't be doing
that
what is this oh come on I don't want to
go to Sears yet
downstairs is bad that sounds very bad
Oh loading screen huh that's how you
gonna run this huh a little what do you
see the same I don't know what is that
hooky stuck in a wall like a frog yeah
you silly [ __ ] hey you weren't scary at
all
uh-uh just yawning really loudly like I
usually do
my vocal warmup nobody need be concerned
about that so if I go back down there
I'm gonna die a horrible death
let's see what kind of horrible death I
will die damn I thought it was stuck in
the wall I thought it wasn't gonna
actually do anything to me chosen oh oh
he's gone yeah about
no no he's there maybe or maybe you're
gonna be
who's that I don't know oh thank you
did you take that no that can't be
anything right no no what huh that
doesn't make any sense I'm running for
it screw this noise I'm out here I'm so
howdy I'm Audi do all that screw you
hold on those people's talking
hey dude
oh no oh I don't know what is what oh oh
okay thank you
sometimes it works sometimes it works if
you push it really a lot what that
happened
what Oh belly oh nothing like Billy's
ninja - neck snaps to get my blood
flowing in the morning I gotta go back
down there
oh no wha I really don't think I can
outrun those things but now I'd Billy it
was he in the elevator and I just didn't
see him or something or what the hell
happened I think like what must happen
is like the second it must have just
been perfectly timed that the second the
door opened I just happened to blink
ah is the monster it is a monster that
is just what the monster sounds like I
got a read up on that s EP as long as it
doesn't see me I'm fine let's go see I'm
dead I'm dead
dad dad I'm dead I'm dead what so
they're not dead am i where is you I
don't know
okay I'm gonna say question right okay
okay so I'm gonna just not die don't die
don't you dare Billy don't
Willy something jumped hello hello oh
good all clear
thank goodness I'm so glad ah come on I
don't have any of that
don't Billy Billy don't
Billy don't be a hero no save damn it
there we go
don't know why it takes a few buttons to
save also my framerate has not been
stellar
Oh shucks who's with that
okay that's normal Rock line was
yep yep yep this is SVP I remember this
I remember all this okay okay okay Hey
hmm
LSE biggest doubt teleport through walls
he absorbed the powers of sepm AR k AI
markiplier I don't know what I'm not
bloody for you oh damn it oh there's
only one way to go into death my Billy a
[ __ ] stop it where you come from oh no
no oh no no no no no no I'm done for
this part but I will play again in the
future if you guys want me to there's a
lot more than that there's a lot more
than have not explored yet and holy crap
I forgot how scary this game could be
especially I'm just taking such a long
breakage between episodes so all of you
guys enjoy this check out the rest of my
SCP containment breach playlist I've
been playing that game this game for
like a year and a half now it has always
been terrifying and always been great so
hopefully you guys can get some
enjoyment out of that if you want more
scare games else got a scare gameplay
let's check it out thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see
in the next video
surprise [ __ ]
what happened